now to Washington where it could be up
to the Senate to avert a national rail
strike that may have devastating
consequences for the economy the house
voted yesterday to push through a deal
which was rejected by some unions
leaving workers wondering if they will
get paid sick leave which they say is
essential Scott McFarland has the story
Tim thank you for Charles Hawkins in the
hardware store he manages in Washington
this is crunch time holiday sales keep
them profitable this feels like a
sensitive time of year for you all for
your business absolutely absolutely
um we pretty much wait the entire year
for uh this even the smallest
interruption or inventory shortage can
rattle the business much less a large
supply chain disruption from a railway
labor strike once things start to sail
you need to replenish so it's very very
important to actually be able to get
things delivered a nearly century-old
law gives Congress the power to resolve
labor disputes involving the nation's
railroads and President Biden asked
Congressional leaders to do so as the
impasse between some rail unions in the
industry is now perilously close to a
December 9th deadline the joint
resolution has passed the house voted on
a bill to force through the latest offer
to rail workers let me be clear in that
Nationwide rail shutdown would be
catastrophic that deal includes 24
percent raises over five years and some
bonus payments but does not include the
seven days of paid sick leave for which
some unions have been fighting our
members told us that sick leave is the
number one concern the people are
working Outdoors they're they're
dangerous jobs in many cases
um so I think you know sick leave is an
important aspect to it the house passed
a separate provision Wednesday to
provide the sick days but the Senate
would have to do the same some
Republicans say they shouldn't be
involved in the first place this
Administration is asking the federal
government to use the force of federal
law to impose contract terms that the
workers have voted against so I'm not
for that
U.S labor secretary Marty Walsh and
transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge meet with Senate Democrats
today with averting this rail strike at
the top of the agenda but Gail there is
still no decision on when the U.S Senate
will vote
and the clock is ticking on this thank
you very much Scott